This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，听从教训。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
以艰难的方式，在Aha广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，“钻石王老五”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。2%。当电梯可用时，走楼梯的人数比例只有这么高。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此脱身。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Thank you for deciding to tune in. This week's episode is essential listening for everyone in their 20s, or really, whatever age you are right now, wherever you are in your life. It is such an important concept, such an important topic.
相信你的闺蜜们。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们：相信我，宝贝》。欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时一些重大的人生改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你在这里。感谢你决定收听。本周的节目对于二十岁左右的每个人来说都是必听的，或者实际上，无论你现在处于什么年龄，无论你的人生处于什么阶段。这是一个如此重要的概念，一个如此重要的话题。
And it's also been a long time coming, something I'm personally really fascinated by, but also excited to be able to share and discuss here. We're talking about the process of nurturing and healing our inner child or reparenting ourselves, healing attachment wounds, by connecting with our childlike wonder, our childlike curiosity and innocence. So you may be wondering, this is a podcast dedicated to people in their 20s. Why are we talking about childhood? That's already happened.
而且这也是酝酿已久的内容，是我个人非常着迷的事情，同时我也很高兴能在这里分享和讨论。我们正在讨论培育和治愈我们内心的小孩或重新养育我们自己的过程，通过连接我们童年时期的惊奇感、童年时期的好奇心和纯真来治愈依恋创伤。所以你可能会想，这是一个专门为二十岁左右的人开设的播客。为什么我们要谈论童年？那已经发生了。
That's in the past. But reconnecting with your inner child is a fundamental task that I believe every single one of us has to do at some point in our lives. And we may as well start now. I think many of us do not take the time to really consider how. our early life experiences have changed and altered us and made us who we are and that whatever has happened in our lives whether you've been hurt you know whether you feel all these obligations to do things whatever society has convinced you whatever society has told you about yourself at the end of the day at our core there is still this tiny innocent vulnerable
那已经是过去式了。但与你内心的小孩重新建立连接是一项基础性的任务，我相信我们每个人在生命中的某个时刻都必须去做。而且我们不妨现在就开始。我想我们很多人都没有花时间去真正思考我们的早期生活经历是如何改变和重塑我们，并造就了今天的我们的；无论我们的人生中发生了什么，无论你是否受过伤害，你知道的，无论你是否觉得有义务去做各种事情，无论社会让你信服了什么，无论社会关于你自己向你灌输了什么，归根结底，在我们内心深处，依然存在着这样一个渺小、天真、脆弱且
joyful version of us that really does deserve to be nurtured and to feel safe. And realizing that can be really life-changing. And I think a massive step in our self-discovery and kind of self-healing and self-growth journey. Before we jump in, I also just want to note that I think that this idea of inner child work, it's been floating around across a lot of platforms like TikTok. and Instagram. I see things about it all the time. And I think with that comes a lot of confusion, I would say, and misinterpretations of the true science and psychology behind this phenomena.
充满欢乐的我们，他们确实值得被悉心呵护并感到安全。意识到这一点真的可以改变人生。我认为这是我们的自我发现以及某种程度上的自我治愈和自我成长旅程中的巨大一步。在我们深入探讨之前，我也只想指出，我认为这种内在小孩工作的理念，一直在TikTok和Instagram等许多平台上流传。我随时都能看到关于它的内容。我认为随之而来的是很多困惑，我想说，还有对这种现象背后的真正科学和心理学的误解。
Often when we see psychology kind of converted onto places like TikTok, when we see it converted into fast media, the concepts kind of lose some of their validity because, you know, it's social media. And we're increasingly skeptical of some of the content that we see on those platforms. So if you're listening to this being like, this sounds like a little bit crazy, this doesn't sound particularly scientific. I understand where you're coming from. But when it comes to healing our inner child, even the existence of our inner child, This is very much a real thing. It has an evidence based behind it.
通常，当我们将心理学转化为TikTok之类的地方时，当我们将它转化为快餐式媒体时，这些概念就会失去一些有效性，因为，你知道的，这是社交媒体。我们对我们在这些平台上看到的一些内容越来越持怀疑态度。所以如果你听到这里觉得，这听起来有点疯狂，这听起来并不是特别科学。我理解你的感受。但当谈到治愈我们内心的小孩，甚至是我们内心小孩的存在时，这绝对是一件真实的事情。它有着循证基础。
Many psychologists have established their entire careers on this idea and on learning more about this connection between our adult selves and our childhood selves on an unconscious level. So I really want to dispel some of that ambiguity today and also provide a bit of a guide as to how we can actually do inner child work on our own. So we're going to discuss the origins of this concept where it came from some of the core elements of what we mean when we talk about our inner child and why it is such a crucial aspect of our identity. Part of that conversation is also some of the wounds that we do carry from childhood. Maybe you've heard of the guilt wound or the abandonment wound.
许多心理学家将他们的整个职业生涯都建立在这个理念之上，并建立在从潜意识层面更多地了解我们成年自我与童年自我之间这种联系的基础之上。所以我今天真的很想消除一些这种模糊性，同时也为我们如何能够真正独自进行内在小孩的工作提供一些指导。因此，我们将讨论这个概念的起源、它来自哪里、当我们谈论我们的内心小孩时其核心要素的一些内容，以及为什么它是我们身份中如此关键的一个部分。对话的一部分还包括我们从童年时代携带的一些创伤。也许你听说过内疚创伤或被抛弃创伤。
I really want to dive further into that as well because I don't think. that the specifics are really talked about enough in this space. Of course, we're going to dissect some of the benefits of reparenting ourselves and of course how we can do this, from the big practices like psychotherapy to just nurturing our innate playfulness, you know, listening to music from our childhood, writing a letter to our childhood selves, giggling every now and again, laughing, playing, all of those things as simple as those practices might sound, we're going to see some amazing differences in how we treat ourselves and how we see the world when we take time to really reflect on what is at our core of our
我真的很想更深入地探讨这一点，因为我不认为在这个领域里，具体的细节得到了足够的讨论。当然，我们会剖析重新养育自己的好处，当然还有我们如何做到这一点，从心理治疗这样的大型实践到仅仅培养我们与生俱来的嬉戏天性，你知道的，听童年时期的音乐，给童年时期的自己写一封信，时不时地咯咯笑，大笑，玩耍，所有这些事情，尽管这些实践听起来很简单，但当我们花时间真正反思什么是我们的核心
identity, how we got to the place that we are, what happened to us in childhood that's made us into this adult version of ourselves. So there's a lot to discuss, a lot to talk through, and so much that we can use in our 20s. So let's jump into all of the information, all of the facts, all of the psychology around how we can heal our inner child. So let's start with the basics. Where did this idea of an inner child come from? And what does it really mean in a modern day context? So the idea as it kind of stands today, it has its roots in the work of Carl Jung. So if you don't know who that is, it's essentially perhaps one of the most well-known, most influential psychiatrists and psychologists from the 1900s. And his work really inspired people like Freud to dive into this
身份、我们是如何走到今天这一步的、我们在童年中发生了什么才让我们变成了成年后的自己时，我们会看到我们在对待自己的方式以及我们看待世界的方式上产生惊人的差异。所以有很多需要讨论的，有很多需要探讨的，有太多我们可以在二十岁时加以利用的东西。让我们直接切入所有的信息、所有的事实、所有关于我们如何治愈内心小孩的心理学。所以让我们从基础开始。内心小孩这个概念是从哪里来的？在现代语境下它到底意味着什么？所以这个概念在今天大致成型时，它的根源在于卡尔·容格（Carl Jung）的著作。所以如果你不知道他是谁，他本质上也许是20世纪最著名、最具影响力的精神病学家和心理学家之一。他的著作真正启发了弗洛伊德等人去深入探讨这一
idea that we have a subconscious or unconscious mind that impacts our daily decisions. So you'll he had this idea, a very in-depth metaphor, that all of us have a child archetype within us, that impacts how we behave, impacts our decisions, how we act, without us really consciously knowing. We all possess this inner version of ourselves, no matter who you are, and like actual children, these inner child archetypes are different. Some of us have a wounded inner child or an innocent inner child and abandoned, or divine or vulnerable inner child. And Jung essentially explained that all of our adult dysfunctions,
观点，即我们拥有一个影响我们日常决策的潜意识或无意识心智。所以你将听到他有这样一个观点，一个非常深入的隐喻，即我们所有人的内心深处都有一个儿童原型，它影响着我们的行为方式，影响着我们的决策、我们的行动，而我们在潜意识中并不真正自知。我们所有人内心都拥有这样版本的自我，无论你是谁，就像现实中的儿童一样，这些内心小孩的原型是不同的。我们中的一些人有一个受伤的内心小孩，或者一个天真的内心小孩，或者一个被抛弃的、神圣的或脆弱的内心小孩。容格本质上解释说，我们所有的成年功能失调，
all of the problems and the quirks and the trauma and the damage that has been done to us in childhood, that is expressed through this archetype. And it's because of this archetype that we act in this way. When we begin to peel back those layers that we've built up to protect ourselves, when we recognize the existence of this subconscious version of us, we're really able to grow, we're able to heal
我们在童年时期所遭遇的所有问题、怪癖、创伤和损害，都是通过这个原型表达出来的。正是因为这个原型，我们才会以这种方式行事。当我们开始剥开为了保护自己而建立的那些层层防御，当我们认识到这个潜意识版本的自己的存在时，我们才真正能够成长，我们才能够治愈，
because we're able to address perhaps what we didn't have as children and the many factors and circumstances and experiences that have made us who we are. That's kind of a simplified way of putting it, and obviously the initial conception has a very, a lot since then, especially as we've begun to understand more about the developmental milestones of children and the impacts of parenting style and trauma. But I think the thing is that our childhood is the most crucial period of our lives, the most crucial developmental period that
因为我们能够去处理或许我们作为儿童时所没有拥有的东西，以及那些造就了今日之我们的诸多因素、环境和经历。这可以说是一种简化的表达方式，显然，最初的概念自那时以来已经有了很大的发展，特别是随着我们开始对儿童的发展里程碑以及育儿风格和创伤的影响有了更多的了解。但我认为关键在于，童年是我们一生中最关键的时期，是我们生命中将经历的最关键的发展时期，
we will go through, not just physically in that it's when we learn how to walk and we develop motor skills and we grow significantly, but also in regards to our emotional and our cognitive functioning and development. We begin to learn our most basic emotions within a matter of weeks of being born. We learn who to trust within a matter of days. By a few years old, we've already begun to form our attachment style. So all of those things that are occurring and happening around us during that time are going to have an impact. Everything since birth is going to influence and impact who we become, from the love that we've been shown to how we've been treated, our childhood environment, those experiences, particularly in terms of our caregiving environment, which we know is super crucial,
不仅在生理上，因为这是我们学习走路、发展运动技能并显著生长的时期，而且在我们的情感和认知功能与发展方面也是如此。我们在出生后的几周内就开始学习最基础的情感。我们在几天内就学会了信任谁。在几岁的时候，我们已经开始形成我们的依恋风格。所以在那段时期发生在我们周围的所有这些事情都将产生影响。自出生以来的每一件事都将影响并塑造我们成为什么样的人，从我们所感受到的爱到我们被对待的方式，我们的童年环境，那些经历，特别是就我们的抚养环境而言，我们知道这是超级关键的，
where most of our hurt comes from, it's going to create kind of the blueprint in interactions with our genetics for our adult selves. It really shapes our brain architecture. In psychology and even philosophy, there is this idea that children are born as a blank canvas on which our experiences slowly build up image after image, layer after layer, until the canvas becomes a lot harder to paint over,
我们大部分的伤害都来源于此，它将与我们的基因相互作用，为我们的成年自我创造出某种蓝图。它确实塑造了我们的脑结构。在心理学甚至哲学中，有一种观点认为，儿童出生时就像一张白纸，我们的经历在上面慢慢累积，一幅画接着一幅画，一层接着一层，直到这张画布变得很难在上面重新绘画，
a lot harder to erase, impossible to start again. Essentially, what I'm saying is that although we might not always think about it, we might not always acknowledge it, the things that we experienced in childhood are going to be one of the single most important determinants for our adult life. And sometimes those childhood experiences, they aren't always positive. And we become severed from our emotional and our creative and our physical and our spiritual needs. and we're wounded or detached from that childlike wonder, from that child version of ourselves. No matter what you've been through though, there's nothing that can remove that inner version of you.
很难擦除，不可能重新开始。本质上，我想说的是，尽管我们可能并不总是去想它，我们可能并不总是承认它，但我们在童年时期经历的事情将成为我们成年生活最单一、最重要的决定因素之一。有时那些童年经历并不总是积极的。我们与自己的情感、创造性、身体和精神需求隔绝了，
The inner child remains. They're always there. And they're the ones that have experienced all of those things that have made us who we are. They're the ones who hold our emotions, who hold our memories, our beliefs, our hopes, our dreams. This incredible article from a psychiatrist out of the US explained it beautifully. Our inner child is the one who remembers what it felt like to giggle uncontrollably. They remember what it felt like to fall asleep in our parents' arms and then get tucked into bed. They remember what it felt like to be excluded, to feel lonely, to feel bullied, to feel rejected.
我们受伤了，或者与那种童年时期的惊奇感、与那个童年版本的自己脱节了。然而，无论你经历过什么，没有什么能抹去你内心的那个版本。内心小孩依然存在。他们总是在那里。他们是经历过所有那些造就了今日之我们的事情的人。他们是承载着我们的情感、承载着我们的记忆、我们的信念、我们的希望、我们的梦想的人。美国一位精神病学家发表的一篇精彩文章对此进行了美妙的阐述。我们内心的小孩还记得无法控制地咯咯笑是什么感觉。他们记得在父母怀里睡着然后被塞进被窝里是什么感觉。他们记得被排挤、感到孤独、感到被欺凌、感到被拒绝是什么感觉。
They remember what it felt like to be yelled at when we were just trying to be good. They remember what it feels like to be abandoned. But on the other side, they also remember what it felt like to play for hours, to go to the beach for the first time, to fall down and have your mom, you know, kiss your wound better, to eat warm cookies, all of those things. Everything that we've learned and felt and experienced since puberty, that hasn't disappeared. That's still here. And sometimes those experiences create negative reactions and negative behaviors and negative habits in adulthood. And
他们记得当我们只是试图表现得乖巧时却被大声斥责是什么感觉。他们记得被抛弃是什么感觉。但在另一面，他们也记得连续玩上几个小时、第一次去海滩、摔倒后让妈妈（你知道的）吻一下伤口以抚平伤痛、吃温热的饼干是什么感觉，所有这些事情。自青春期以来我们所学到、感受到和经历的一切，并没有消失。它依然在这里。有时这些经历会在成年期产生负面反应、负面行为和负面习惯。
that's when we would say that someone has a wounded inner child. And the way to kind of identify that that might be an experience someone's had and that their inner child is wounded is by the adult behaviors that they portray. So things like a difficulty trusting others, emotional unavailability, feeling guilty or undeserving of nice things, even nice emotions like love and generosity, people pleasing behaviors, that's a really big one,
而这时我们会说某人有一个受伤的内心小孩。辨别一个人可能经历过这种情况以及他们的内心小孩受伤了的方式，就是通过他们表现出的成年人行为。比如难以信任他人、情感疏离、感到内疚或不配拥有美好的事物，甚至是爱与慷慨这样美好的情感，讨好型人格，这是一个非常大的特征，
abandonment issues, feeling that you need to collect people or collect friendships, difficulty trust, others, I think I already said that, but it is a massive one that comes up quite a bit. Or you might suppress really hard emotions. These are all indicators that we have a wounded inner child. And that's essentially the basis for inner child healing.
有被抛弃情结，觉得自己需要收集人脉或收集友谊，难以信任他人，我想我之前已经说过这个了，但这是一个非常突出的问题。或者你可能会压抑强烈的情感。这些都是我们内心小孩受伤的指标。这本质上就是内在小孩疗愈的基础。
The essential premise is that we've all experienced hurt in some way. And in order to heal our adult scars, our adult wounds, our adult beliefs, we have to go back to the root or the cause of that problem, which is the foundational experiences that we had as children. Inner child work, like any other type of work, involves hard decisions. It involves time. It involves energy. But it also involves creating a safe space where your subconscious, your inner child,
其核心前提是，我们所有人都曾以某种方式经历过伤害。为了治愈我们成年后的伤疤、我们成年后的创伤、我们成年后的信念，我们必须回到那个问题的根源或起因，也就是我们在童年时期经历的基础体验。内在小孩的工作，就像任何其他类型的工作一样，涉及艰难的决定。它需要时间。它需要精力。但它也涉及创建一个安全空间，让你的潜意识、你的内心小孩，
is really able to take the lead, is really able to express themselves and have a voice and have freedom. By creating that space for yourself, you give yourself permission to explore the significant events that were perhaps uncomfortable or unpleasant to get in touch with your true feelings and parts of you that you've rejected, parts of you that you've suppressed because you thought they were unlovable or you thought they were too much or you thought they were embarrassing. And there are a couple ways that we can do that, some of which are more valid or evidence-based than others. But before you jump right in, I think it's important to understand what kind of childhood or inner child wound you're trying to heal. I think one of the big misconceptions around this type of work, around this type of healing,
能够真正占据主导地位，能够真正表达自己，拥有声音和自由。通过为自己创造这个空间，你允许自己去探索那些可能令人不舒服或令人不快的重要事件，去接触你真实的感受以及你拒绝的那部分自己，那些你因为觉得它们不可爱、或者觉得它们太多了、或者觉得它们令人尴尬而压抑的自己。我们可以通过几种方法来做到这一点，其中一些比另一些更有效或更有循证依据。但在你直接跳进去之前，我认为重要的是要了解你正试图治愈哪种童年或内在小孩创伤。我认为围绕这种类型的工作、这种类型的治愈的一个重大误解是，
is that it's only reserved for those with really intense familial and relational trauma. And there's no doubt that in those cases, it's highly beneficial. But I don't think anyone goes through life without a couple of scars. And what we may suppress and see as minor, or we may dismiss as being. no big deal, those events, those experiences can actually be highly influential, especially when we consider that as children we were so vulnerable, we had such limited coping skills. And there's even cases in which we become stuck at the age in which the trauma occurred, unable to really move forward. A reminder, like we always say on the show, trauma is subjective.
它只保留给那些有非常严重的家庭和人关联创伤的人。毫无疑问，在这些情况下，它是高度受益的。但我不认为任何人能不带几道伤疤走过一生。我们可能压抑并视之为微不足道的事情，或者我们可能不以为然地认为这没什么大不了的，这些事件、这些经历实际上可能会产生巨大的影响，特别是考虑到作为儿童的我们是如此脆弱，我们的应对能力如此有限。甚至还存在这样一种情况，我们在创伤发生时的年龄停滞不前，无法真正向前迈进。提醒一下，就像我们总在节目中所说的那样，创伤是主观的。
What may be intense and extreme and severe for one person might not be the same for someone else. But everyone is carrying something with them. We all have different sensitivities. We all have different temperaments. And the content of the experience is not something that we should judge against other people's experiences. It's not some kind of competition. I think everyone's experiences are valid. it doesn't really matter what kind of severity level you think it was.
对一个人来说可能是强烈、极端和严重的事情，对另一个人来说可能并非如此。但每个人都在随身携带一些东西。我们都有不同的敏感度。我们都有不同的气质。经历的内容不应该拿来与别人的经历作比较。这又不是什么比赛。我认为每个人的经历都是有效的。你认为它的严重程度如何其实并不重要。
It's important to acknowledge that the only thing that really matters in this instance is how you feel and the individual impact that it's had on you. Once you start on this journey, you may find that a lot of the behaviours or habits that you currently have that you've learned can be traced back to childhood experiences. For example, if you tend to lash out, become really frustrated and aggressive when you're rejected, it may be because as a child you didn't have the proper coping skills to deal with a caregiver walking out of your life or feeling abandoned by someone who was meant to help you, someone who was meant to love you. or if you shut down when you feel really intense emotions or really intense sadness,
重要的是要承认，在这种情况下唯一真正重要的只有你的感受以及它对你产生的个人影响。一旦你踏上这段旅程，你可能会发现你目前拥有的许多行为或习惯都是可以追溯到童年经历的。例如，如果你倾向于抨击，在被拒绝时变得非常沮丧和具有攻击性，那可能是因为作为儿童时，你没有适当的应对技巧来处理照顾者走出你的生活或被一个本应帮助你、本应爱你的人抛弃的感觉。或者，如果你在感到非常强烈的情感或非常强烈的悲伤时选择关闭自己，
it may be because you weren't allowed to properly express those emotions as a child. Often these reactions stem from what psychologists call childhood wounds. And there are four typical wounds that we generally hear psychologists talk about when they talk about inner child trauma or healing your inner child. And these are the guilt wound, the abandonment wound, the trust wound and the neglect wound. Each of these have their own origins, have their own indicators, but they also have their own exercises and way of healing. Firstly, the guilt wound often comes from childhood experiences in which you felt
那可能是因为你在童年时不允许适当地表达这些情绪。通常这些反应源于心理学家所说的童年创伤。当心理学家谈论内在小孩创伤或治愈你的内在小孩时，我们通常会听到四种典型创伤。它们分别是内疚创伤、被抛弃创伤、信任创伤和忽视创伤。每一种都有其自身的起源、自身的表征，但它们也有各自的练习和治愈方式。首先，内疚创伤通常源于这样的童年经历：你觉得
that you had to take care of everybody, that you experienced way more responsibility at a young age than you probably should have. Maybe you were responsible for a really ill parent or a sibling and you were made to feel kind of guilty for asking for your needs to be met or undeserving of basic emotional and physical necessities because someone else's needs always took precedence over your own. As a child, you may have responded to this by trying really hard to be good, by always feeling guilty or really susceptible to guilt-tripping or manipulation from those in your life. How does that manifest in adulthood? Well, an unaddressed wound of this nature, it may result in really severe people-pleasing tendencies.
你必须照顾每个人，你在很小的时候就承担了远比你可能应该承担的多的责任。也许你要对一个重病的父母或兄弟姐妹负责，而且当你要求满足自己的需求时，你会感到内疚，或者觉得自己不配拥有基本的情感和身体必需品，因为别人的需求总是凌驾于你自己的需求之上。作为儿童，你可能会通过努力表现得乖巧来应对这一点，总是感到内疚，或者非常容易受到生活中那些人的情感绑架或操纵。这在成年期是如何表现的呢？好吧，这种性质的未解决创伤，可能会导致非常严重的讨好型人格倾向，
you know you need to constantly apologize you feel guilty for saying no to things that you really don't want to do and you find yourself in situations in which they're almost codependent in which you're giving someone a lot of your energy and time and feel guilty if you ever need to take a step back to heal this wound most therapists i would say would probably recommend that you build your skills surrounding healthy bowel boundary setting, that you build up your confidence in being able to demand your wants, demand your needs, and set a boundary when those are not being met. This might look like accountability around how many times you apologize to others, reiterating that you don't need to say sorry
你知道你需要不断道歉，你对拒绝自己真正不想做的事情感到内疚，你发现自己陷入了几乎是共生关系的情境中，你在其中付出了大量的精力和时间给别人，如果你需要退后一步来治愈这个创伤，你就会感到内疚。大多数治疗师可能会建议你建立围绕健康边界设置的技能，建立你能够要求满足自己的愿望、要求满足自己的需求并在这些需求未得到满足时设定边界的自信。这可能看起来像是对你向他人道歉的次数进行问责，重申你不需要一直说对不起，
all the time, that you have nothing to be sorry for. You're just looking out for yourself, you're just prioritizing yourself. And also, exercises and work around forgiveness and self-forgiveness. I saw this really amazing exercise or really amazing kind of practice that the psychologist was talking about in which you journal the things that you feel guilty for, and then at the end of each one you simply say, I forgive you. And you picture it's your inner child who you're forgiving. And you just sit in front of them in your imagination and just say, I forgive you. There's no need to be sorry.
你没有什么好对不起的。你只是在照顾自己，你只是在优先考虑自己。还有关于宽恕和自我宽恕的练习和工作。我看到了一个非常棒的练习或某种非常棒的实践，心理学家在谈论它时提到，你将你感到内疚的事情写在日记里，然后在每一项的结尾，你只需说：我原谅你。然后你想象那是你正在原谅的内心小孩。你在想象中坐在他们面前，然后说：我原谅你。不需要道歉。
It sounds so simple, but if you've never done that before, if you've never addressed that aspect of your childhood before, it's going to feel really profound and highly emotional. The second common wound is that abandonment wound that we were talking about before. Perhaps, I think, the one that receives the most acknowledgement, this type of wound, it kind of stems from the feeling that at some stage in your childhood, you were abandoned by someone who was meant to care for you. You were left behind, resulting in you feeling like you did something wrong.
听起来很简单，但如果你从来没有这样做过，如果你从未解决过你童年的那一方面，这将会感觉非常深刻且极具情绪化。第二个常见的创伤是我们之前谈到的被抛弃创伤。也许，我认为，这是获得最多认可的一个，这种类型的创伤，它源于这样一种感觉：在童年时期的某个阶段，你被一个本该照顾你的人抛弃了。你被抛下了，导致你觉得是不是自己做错了什么。
That was how you deserved to be treated. It's most often associated with people whose parents were perhaps in the midst of a divorce or separating. Maybe you had a parent pass away or who was very distant. And as you get older, what that manifests in is, deep fears of being abandoned, deep fears of being rejected. You might become very fixated on people, but also incredibly anxious when you sense even the slightest indicator that they might leave, that they might walk away. You find yourself in codependent relationships, or also on the flip side find it very difficult to trust others because you've been taught that and primed, I guess,
那是你应得的待遇。它最常与父母处于离婚或分居之中的人联系在一起。也许你有一个父母去世了或非常冷漠。随着你年龄的增长，这表现为对被抛弃的深度恐惧，对被拒绝的深度恐惧。你可能会对人变得非常执着，但当你感觉到哪怕最微小的他们可能会离开、可能会走开的迹象时，也会变得异常焦虑。你发现自己陷入了共生关系中，或者另一方面，由于你受到的教导和潜移默化的影响，你发现很难信任他人，
that you're going to be hurt. This reaction, it always makes me so sad. And I think when we're talking about in a child work, it can make it particularly profound and emotional to imagine that the version of you now that is experiencing those things, all of that originated from the experiences that you had to have when you were young
你会受到伤害。这种反应总是让我感到很难过。我认为当我们谈论内在小孩的工作时，想象现在的那个正在经历这些事情的版本的你，这一切都源于你年幼时不得不经历的那些经历，
and when you were vulnerable. To heal this, I think, you really have to unpack those feelings. You really have to unpack that aband that abandonment with a therapist, I think that can be highly beneficial. Repeating positive affirmations is another one that you deserve to be loved, reminding yourself that the right person will stay, and that your worth is not valued by others' decisions.
当你脆弱的时候，这会使其变得尤其深刻和情绪化。为了治愈这一点，我认为，你真的必须解开这些情绪。我认为与治疗师一起解开那种被抛弃感，会是非常有益的。重复积极的肯定语是另一种方法，即你值得被爱，提醒自己对的人会留下，你的价值不是由别人的决定来衡量的。
The third wound I want to touch on is the betrayal wound. As a child, you may have felt that you could not trust your caregivers, that they failed to fulfill their promises. to you, they would gaslight you, they would put you down or put you in situations in which you weren't safe. They didn't stand up for you when you needed it. And as a result, you've become hyper-independent and you're unable to trust others. You find it really uncomfortable and unnatural to allow others to take care of you or to show you generosity just because they want to. You know, you're constantly questioning their intentions because of this experience that you had when you were younger.
我想触及的第三个创伤是背叛创伤。作为儿童，你可能觉得你无法信任你的照顾者，他们没有兑现对你的承诺，他们会对你进行煤气灯操纵（精神控制），他们会贬低你或把你置于不安全的境地。在你需要的时候，他们没有为你挺身而出。结果，你变得过度独立，无法信任他人。你发现让别人照顾你或仅仅因为他们想对你好而向你展示慷慨，是一件非常不舒服且很不自然的事情。你知道的，因为你年轻时的这段经历，你一直在质疑他们的意图。
I think building your own trust in yourself, but also surrendering and letting go and allowing yourself to trust others is really valuable in this situation. Sometimes it can be really hard to be stoic about it, especially when you are expecting to get hurt. but stoicism might just be the way forward, being like, okay, I need to remain somewhat detached from the situation, allow myself to float along with this, allow myself to be loved, knowing that no matter what happens, I will be okay. Finally, we have the neglect wound, which often comes from feeling that as a child, you were not supported and you didn't receive your emotional needs, your physical needs, your cognitive, your social needs, you were ignored or treated as an afterthought. And this can come from parents and family, but also from teachers and mentors. An example of this that I saw from someone who was recounting their experience, healing from a neglect wound, was a situation in which her sibling was highly successful.
我认为在这种情况建立对自己的信任，同时也顺其自然、放手并允许自己去信任他人是非常有价值的。有时要对此保持泰然处之真的很困难，特别是当你预期会受到伤害时。但泰然处之可能正是前进的道路，表现得像：好吧，我需要与这种情况保持某种程度的疏离，允许自己随波逐流，允许自己被爱，知道无论发生什么，我都会好起来的。最后，我们有忽视创伤，这通常源于这样一种感觉：作为儿童，你没有得到支持，没有得到你的情感需求、身体需求、认知、社会需求的满足，你被忽视了，或者被当作无足轻重的人对待。这可能来自父母和家庭，但也可能来自老师和导师。我看到过一个经历过忽视创伤并从中康复的人讲述的一个例子，那是她的兄弟姐妹非常成功的情况。
I think they were like a child actor. And she wasn't. She wasn't. She wasn't successful. She didn't want to do movies. She didn't want to be the next Lindsay Lohan, whatever it was. But what that resulted in was her parents constantly giving preferential treatment to this other sibling. These situations, they can be super nuanced and different for everyone. But often this childhood wound results in low self-worth, a pessimistic outlook on life, repressing. and suppressing our true feelings and lowering our standards for our relationships. To nurture an inner child who has experienced this, therapists and psychologists, they've come up with some amazing exercises, mainly to do with honoring and expressing our feelings through what they call shameless release. Be that, you know, screaming at the top of your lungs in the forest or in nature, screaming the lyrics to a cathartic song in your car or creating art that allows you to bring
我想他们就像是个童星。而她不是。她不是。她不成功。她不想拍电影。她不想成为下一个林赛·罗韩，无论那是什么。但结果是她的父母不断对这个兄弟姐妹给予偏爱。这些情况可能非常微妙，对每个人来说都不同。但通常这种童年创伤会导致低自尊、对生活悲观的看法、压抑我们真实的情感，并降低我们对人际关系的标准。为了培育一个经历过这种经历的内心小孩，治疗师和心理学家想出了一些惊人的练习，主要与通过他们所谓的无耻释放来尊重和表达我们的情感有关。无论是，你知道的，在森林里或大自然中歇斯底里地尖叫，在车里大声唱出一首宣泄性的歌曲的歌词，或者创作艺术，让你能够把
your emotions to the surface and express them freely and with beauty and without shame. Additionally, I think children who have experienced this type of upbringing, they're very used to hearing no, they're very used to hearing people not give them what they want. And I don't mean, you know, giving them junk food all the time, but I mean giving them their most basic needs and wants. So to heal that, maybe that involves saying yes to yourself. You're now your own parent, right? You're reparenting that inner child.
你的情感带到表面，自由地表达它们，带着美感，没有羞耻。此外，我认为经历过这种养育方式的儿童，他们非常习惯听到“不”，他们非常习惯听到人们不给他们想要的东西。我不是指，你知道的，一直给他们垃圾食品，而是指给他们最基本的需求和愿望。所以为了治愈这一点，也许这涉及对你自己说“是”。你现在是自己的父母了，对吧？你在重新养育那个内心小孩。
So say yes to the food that you want to eat. Buy yourself something because it makes you happy, even if it's impractical. Say yes to nice things like nights out with your friends and going to the movies just because you want to, you're the parent now. That's your role in this healing journey. You have to look after your inner child and treat them with the love and generosity that you deserved, but maybe you didn't receive.
所以对你想吃的食物说“是”。给自己买点东西，因为这能让你快乐，即使它不切实际。对美好的事物说“是”，比如和朋友出去玩夜晚、去看电影，仅仅因为你想去，你现在是父母了。这是你在这段治愈之旅中的角色。你必须照顾你的内心小孩，用你应得的但可能没有得到的爱和慷慨对待他们。
I think regardless of this wound, regardless of whether you think you had a guilt wound or an abandonment wound or a betrayal wound, it's also about accountability. When we embark on the journey of reparenting, we recognise that caring for our inner child, it isn't just being goofy and silly and giving in to all our whims and wants and desires, but it's also about making hard decisions. We wouldn't allow our actual child to eat junk food all day and say yes to every social event to the point where they were exhausted. or continue being friends with people who brought them down. So you can't allow yourself and your own inner child to accept that treatment either.
我认为无论是什么创伤，无论你认为自己有内疚创伤、被抛弃创伤还是背叛创伤，这同样关乎问责。当我们踏上重新养育的旅程时，我们意识到照顾我们的内心小孩，不仅仅是滑稽、愚蠢、纵容我们所有的突发奇想、愿望和渴望，它还关乎做出艰难的决定。我们不会允许我们现实中的孩子整天吃垃圾食品，并且对每一个社交活动都说“是”直到他们筋疲力尽。或者继续和那些让他们情绪低落的人交朋友。所以你也不能允许你自己和你自己的内心小孩接受那种对待。
It's just as much about responsibility as it is about compassion and love. They come hand in hand. I think it's worth mentioning. We listed out those typical childhood wounds. And I think that they sound really intense. Often when we list them out, when we dissect them, it can really seem that they're rooted in a lot of extreme trauma. But like I said before, neglect, abandonment, guilt, betrayal,
这既关乎责任，也关乎同情和爱。它们齐头并进。我认为值得一提的是。我们列出了那些典型的童年创伤。我认为它们听起来真的很强烈。通常当我们列出它们、剖析它们时，确实似乎它们植根于许多极端的创伤中。但就像我之前说的，忽视、抛弃、内疚、背叛，
these can all occur on a micro level as well, on a micro scale, even in ways that we don't always recognize because of the subconscious nature of our inner child. I truly believe that no matter how hard you think you had it or how easy, all of us deserve the opportunity to show our inner child love and compassion. It's just a good practice to have because not only can it help us resolve problematic behaviours that are rooted in our childhood experiences, it can also just let us tap into that joy and tap into that silliness that I think a lot of us lose as we get older. And how sad is that?
这些也可能发生在微观层面上，在微观尺度上，甚至以我们由于内心小孩的潜意识性质而并不总是意识到的方式发生。我坚信，无论你认为你的经历有多艰难或多轻松，我们所有人都值得有机会向我们的内心小孩表达爱和同情。这只是一种很好的实践，因为不仅可以帮助我们解决植根于童年经历的问题行为，它还可以让我们接入那种快乐，接入那种许多人在年长后似乎都失去了的幼稚。这难道不令人难过吗？
How sad that we're not allowed to be silly and we're not allowed to play. We become hardened by adulthood and seriousness and obligations and expectations and jobs and bills. But giving yourself space to release those constraints, it is truly emotional magic. So I want to dive into some of those specific practices that I'm. use that I know other people use for reconnecting with your inner childlike wonder and joy and how you can make that part of your daily routine. It always shocks me to think of how many people out there leave their childhoods and never think about it again or how many people are so serious about what it means to be an adult,
我们不被允许幼稚，不被允许玩耍，这难道不令人难过吗？我们被成年和严肃、义务、期望、工作和账单磨得冷硬。但给自己空间去释放这些束缚，真的是一种情绪上的魔法。所以我想要深入探讨一些具体的实践，我知道其他人也用这些实践来重新连接你内心童年的惊奇感与快乐，以及你如何将其作为你日常生活的一部分。每当想到外面有多少人离开童年就再也不去回想，或者有多少人对成年意味着什么如此认真，
that they are completely opposed to play or to laughter, as if those things no longer have value once we reach a certain age. But activities like playing children's card games or listening to music from your childhood, re-watching old favorite movies, buying yourself snacks that are normally reserved for children, they're honestly such a mood booster. And more than that, they're amazing for our mental and emotional health.
以至于他们完全反对玩耍或笑声，就好像这些东西一旦我们达到某个年龄就不再有价值了一样，这总是让我感到震惊。但诸如玩儿童纸牌游戏或听童年的音乐、重温以前最喜欢的电影、给自己买通常留给儿童的零食这样的活动，老实说，真的是极好的情绪助推器。不仅如此，它们对我们的心理和情感健康也是惊人的。
That's one of the amazing parts about being an adult is that now you can say yes to the things that as a child you wanted to do all the time. The other day, I had a friend bring orange slices to a soccer game I was playing, and let me tell you, the absolute delight that brought me was insane. I could just feel baby Gemma being so happy, feeling so deep, feeling so nurtured, so looked after, and we can create that feeling for ourselves. So maybe you're not a big fan of orange slices or board games, but what are some of the ways that we can not only recognize our inner child, but nurture them, love them, heal them,
这是成为成年人最美妙的部分之一，现在你可以对那些小时候一直想做的事情说“是”。前几天，我有一个朋友在我踢的一场足球比赛中带来了橙子切片，让我告诉你，那给我带来的绝对喜悦是疯狂的。我能感觉到小杰玛是多么快乐，感到那么深刻，感到被悉心呵护，被照顾得很好，我们可以为自己创造那种感觉。所以也许你不是橙子切片或棋盘游戏的超级粉丝，但我们还有哪些方式不仅能识别我们的内心小孩，还能培育他们、爱他们、治愈他们，
and allow that part of us to live on in how we treat ourselves and how we treat others? Staying in tune with your inner child's presence, it all begins with ignoring. You cannot have a relationship with this version of you if you don't acknowledge that it exists or you choose to stay ignorant to its influence. Kim Eagle, a therapist in the US, she made this amazing point in an article she wrote on this and I think it's so important to share here. Anyone can get in touch with their inner child if they're open to exploring this relationship. if you feel doubtful or resistant to this idea of exploring the past, if you feel doubtful that this version of you even still exists,
并让那部分的自己继续存在于我们对待自己和对待他人的方式中？保持与你内心小孩存在的契合，这一切都始于忽视。如果你不承认它的存在，或者你选择对它的影响保持无知，你就无法与这个版本的自己建立关系。金·伊格尔（Kim Eagle），美国的一位治疗师，她在为此撰写的一篇文章中提出了这个精彩的观点，我认为在这里分享非常重要。任何人都可以与他们的内心小孩接触，只要他们愿意探索这段关系。如果你对探索过去的这种想法感到怀疑或抗拒，如果你怀疑这个版本的自己是否甚至还存在，
you're going to have a harder time beginning the healing process. I think a great place to start is to reconnect with the things that remind you of the childhood version of yourself and take note of how exposure to these things makes you feel. For example, the other day I watched the Hannah Montana movie. I know. Huge throwback. But that movie was released when I was nine years old and I was obsessed with it. I was a massive Miley Cyrus fan. I loved that movie. I memorized all the songs. I brought clothes like Miley Cyrus. I think I watched that movie like in the cinema four times. And rewatching it at 23 made me so incredibly emotional,
你将更难开启治愈过程。我认为一个很好的起点是重新连接那些让你想起童年版本自己的事物，并注意接触这些事物如何让你感觉。例如，前几天我看了《汉娜·蒙塔娜》电影。我知道。巨大的回忆杀。但那部电影在我九岁时上映，我简直迷恋它。我是麦莉·赛勒斯的超级粉丝。我太喜欢那部电影了。我背下了所有的歌曲。我模仿麦莉·赛勒斯穿衣服。我想我在电影院里把那部电影看了大约四次。在23岁时重新观看它让我感到无比的情绪化，
but also aware of the childhood version of myself. That positive reaction reminded me that she existed because those emotions I was experiencing, they were derived from memories of that time. They were derived from the joy that baby Gemma, childhood Gemma, had for that movie, the memories that she had made. And that moment, that wonder,
但同时也意识到童年时期的自己。那个积极的反应提醒我，她之所以存在，是因为我当时经历的那些情感，都源于那个时期的记忆。它们源于小杰玛、童年杰玛对那部电影的热爱，以及她所创造的记忆。那一刻，那种惊叹，
that emotion of rewatching something that meant so much to me as a child, that emotion wouldn't have occurred if those memories didn't already exist and if she hadn't existed and been feeling those exact same things at some point in time. If you're feeling detached from your inner child, try and recreate moments and memories from childhood to reorientate your current conscious version of you and your former subconscious version of you, your childhood version of you. that can be aided like things like smell and sound and sight.
那种重温对我童年意义非凡的事物的情感，如果这些记忆本来就不存在，如果她没有存在并在某个时刻感受到完全相同的那些东西，这种情感就不会发生。如果你觉得与内心的孩童疏离了，试着重现童年的时刻和记忆，来重新调整你当前有意识的自己和过去的潜意识自己，也就是你童年的自己。气味、声音和视觉等事物可以对此有所帮助。
Activities like watching a classic movie, cooking your favorite childhood meal or reading your favorite childhood book because our memories are strongest when they're tied to multiple senses. So you'll be amazed by how much your mind and body responds to these experiences from a procedural and unconscious place and how in touch you feel. with that former version of you. The other tip I have, and I'm guessing many of us have heard of this before, but change your phone background to a photo of your childhood self. Right now. Do it right now. Ask your mom, ask your grandma, your aunt for a photo of you when you were five or six years
诸如看经典电影、烹制你最喜欢的童年美食或阅读你最喜欢的童年书籍之类的活动，因为当我们的记忆与多种感官绑定时，它们是最强大的。因此，你会惊叹于你的心灵和身体对这些来自程序性和无意识层面的体验的反应有多大，以及你感觉与那个过去的自己有多么亲近。我有的另一个建议，我猜我们很多人以前都听过，那就是把你的手机壁纸换成你童年时期的照片。马上。现在就做。向你妈妈、你奶奶、你阿姨要一张你五六岁时的照片，
old and make that the first thing you see every day. I have a photo of me from like when I was in fourth grade, next to my computer at home, and anytime I'm working or getting stressed out at my job, I just look to my left and I'm reminded that everything I'm putting myself through, everything I'm doing, I'm also doing to her. And would that version of me, would that little baby version of me be proud of me right now? Is this what her dream was? Would she be happy with where we are now? Would she be happy with what we're doing? And it really puts your decision, and your treatment of yourself into perspective, and I found that it's made me a lot more gentle in my self-judgment.
并把它作为你每天看到的第一个东西。我有一张我大约在四年级时的照片，放在家里电脑旁边，每当我在工作中工作或感到压力时，我只需向左看，就会提醒自己，我所经历的一切，我所做的一切，我其实也是在对她做。那么那个时期的我，那个小小的婴儿时期的我会为现在的我感到骄傲吗？这真的是她的梦想吗？她会对我们现在的处境感到高兴吗？她会对我们正在做的事感到高兴吗？这确实能让你对自己的决定和对自己的对待有一个正确的审视，我发现这让我对自己进行自我批判时变得温柔多了。
Other things I find really useful. I've said this before, but like engaging in play. You know, go and play tag every once in a while. Pull out those Monopoly or Uno cards. Make yourself like a really big chocolate Sunday. Buy yourself something, I don't know, ridiculously fluffy just because you want to. pretend that you are taking the little version of you out for like the best day ever and give them everything that they would have wanted then buy them ridiculous candy that is just full of sugar and
我觉得非常有用的其他事情。我以前说过，那就是参与游戏。你知道，偶尔去玩一下捉迷藏。拿出那些大富翁或优诺牌。给自己做一个超级大的巧克力圣代。给自己买点什么，我不知道，仅仅因为你想买就买个荒谬蓬松的东西；假装你带著小小的自己去过有史以来最棒的一天，给他们想要的一切，给他们买荒谬的充满糖分的糖果，
looks disgusting but your inner child wants it sing along to your favorite songs feel joyful go and look at children's books in the bookstore it's a great step towards healing through acknowledgement of that past version of you i think this really really links with the next step to healing and connecting with your inner child, and that is to put your acknowledgement into practice. Being aware of your inner child is one thing, being in touch with them, and giving yourself the space to be vulnerable and to nurture them is another. The biggest impact, this relationship or journey has brought to my adult life, is the way I now speak to myself, and the way that I honour my emotions and my feelings.
看起来很恶心但你内心的孩童想要它，跟着你最喜欢的歌一起唱歌，感受快乐，去书店看儿童读物，这是通过承认过去的自己来走向治愈的绝佳一步。我认为这真的与治愈和连接你内心的孩童的下一步息息相关，那就是将你的认可付诸实践。意识到你内心的孩童是一回事，与他们保持联系，并给自己留出空间去脆弱和滋养他们则是另一回事。这段关系或旅程给我成年生活带来的最大影响，是我现在对自己说话的方式，以及我尊重自己情绪和感受的方式。
I think we all have this tendency to be very hard on ourselves, to say things to ourselves that we would never imagine saying to someone else mean things, hurtful things. That is terrible for our self-worth and our identity, but also a hard habit to break out of. Being in touch with your inner child is really useful for that. when you find that you've failed, when you've been rejected, when you feel unhappy with yourself, take note of your inner dialogue and imagine that your five-year-old self is sitting in front of you right now
我想我们所有人都有这样一种倾向，对自己的要求非常严苛，对自已说一些我们绝不会对别人说的话——刻薄的话、伤人的话。这对我们的自我价值和认同感是极其糟糕的，但也是一个很难改掉的习惯。与你内心的孩童保持联系对此非常有用。当你发现自己失败了、被拒绝了、对自已感到不开心时，留意一下你的内心独白，想象你五岁的自己此刻正坐在你面前，
and you're saying those things to them. You wouldn't yell at your childhood version of you. You wouldn't yell at your five-year-old version of yourself. You wouldn't call them fat. You wouldn't tell them they're useless. You wouldn't tell them. that they're worthless or they're stupid. So why would you say those things to yourself now? Once you acknowledge that that version of you is still within you, it completely changes your perspective. And the same goes for how you let others treat you. If you wouldn't let someone treat a child the way that your friends or your partner or your parents or your colleagues treat you, then a boundary needs to be put in place.
而你正在对他们说那些话。你不会对童年时期的自己大喊大叫。你不会对自己五岁的版本大喊大叫。你不会叫他们胖子。你不会告诉他们他们一无是处。你不会告诉他们他们毫无价值或者很愚蠢。那你现在为什么要对自己说这些话呢？一旦你承认那个时期的你依然在你体内，它就会彻底改变你的视角。你如何让别人对待你也同样如此。如果你不会让别人像你的朋友、伴侣、父母或同事对待你那样去对待一个孩子，那么你就需要划定界限。
Obviously, we have more emotional maturity at this age than we did as children. So someone offering you constructive criticism or asking you to do your job or to be independent, that may seem intense for a child, but acceptable for an adult. I think it goes without saying that healing your inner child isn't about regressing to that version of you. It's about being better at acknowledging how people and situations make you feel. where that reaction may have come from and how you can properly respond to that from a place of maturity but also acknowledging your own emotions. I want to leave you with a few final strategies and practices that you can integrate into your life that have been shown to really improve how people emotionally connect with themselves by connecting with the vision of their younger selves first. Firstly, do something creative.
显然，我们在这个年龄比小时候拥有更多的情感成熟度。因此，如果有人对你提出建设性的批评，或者要求你做好工作或保持独立，这对于一个孩子来说可能显得有些强烈，但对于一个成年人来说是可以接受的。不言而喻，治愈你内心的孩童并不是要倒退回那个时期的你。而是要更好地认识到人们和情况带给你什么样的感受、这种反应可能来自何处，以及你如何能够以一种成熟的方式对此作出恰当的回应，同时也要承认你自己的情绪。我想留给你一些最后的策略和实践，你可以将它们融入你的生活，事实证明，这些策略和实践通过先与年轻时自己的愿景连接，确实能显著改善人们与自己的情感连接。首先，做一些有创造力的事。
You know, when we were children, we used to have art class as part of our curriculum. You know, do you remember you used to have like a period every couple of weeks where you would go and just make art all the time and you'd wear your little smocks? We don't always have time to do that as we get older. We don't always make the time to do that. But we can integrate that if we make it a priority. If we make it a priority to heal and connect with that inner version of us. go to a life drawing class, go to a pottery class, take up knitting by coloring books, any of those things. A study from the journal Frontiers in Psychology, they published this article in 2019 that found that art doing something creative,
你知道，当我们还是孩子的时候，美术课曾是我们课程的一部分。你知道，你还记得你以前每隔几个星期就会有一段时间去上美术课，然后穿上你的小罩衫吗？随着我们长大，我们并不总是有时间这样做。我们并不总是为此抽出时间。但如果我们把它当作优先事项，我们就可以将这一点融入其中。如果我们把治愈和连接我们内心的那个版本作为优先事项。去上写生课，去上陶艺课，学织毛衣，买填色书，任何这些都可以。《边疆心理学杂志》上的一项研究在2019年发表了一篇文章，发现艺术——做一些有创造力的事，
it improves health and well-being amongst basically every individual who was studied. It promoted resilience, it promoted coping skills, and overall happiness levels. but it's something we don't always do as adults. So it's a way of reconnecting with that inner childlike wonder to bring happiness to the adult version of you, to your adult life. The second thing is to be messy. Mess is so acceptable in childhood, but not so much in adulthood. Find a way to let yourself step out of the constraints of
它能改善几乎所有被研究的个体的健康和福祉。它提升了复原力、应对技巧以及整体幸福感。但这并不是我们成年后总会去做的事。所以这是一种与内心的童真重新连接的方式，从而为成年的你、你的成年生活带来快乐。第二件事是制造混乱。混乱在童年时期是如此被接受，但在成年后却不那么被接受。找一种方法让自己跳出那种总是需要干净、整洁和井井有条的束缚，
always needing to be clean and tidy and put together, you know, cook with rash abandon, make a mess. Repots and plants, get your hands dirty. It's good for your neurons. It's good for your synaptic connections and growth and it's good for your happiness. This one was really sweet. And when I read it, I was like, this is gorgeous. I want to integrate this into my life. Hug yourself. I know it sounds really, really strange. And we often think that we need to receive physical touch from others, which is very much true. But any form of being touched really does release a lot of oxytocin, which is otherwise known as the happiness or pleasure hormone. And we can release that ourselves. Our brain can't always tell the difference between someone giving you a big hug and you
带着随心所欲的冲劲去烹饪，搞得一团糟。重新种植植物，把你的手弄脏。这有益于你的神经元。它有益于你的突触连接和生长，并且有益于你的幸福。这一点真的很甜。当我读到它时，我想：这太棒了。我想把它融入我的生活。拥抱你自己。我知道这听起来真的很奇怪。我们经常认为我们需要接受来自他人的身体接触，这确实是事实。但任何形式的被接触确实都会释放大量的催产素，它也被称为快乐或愉悦荷尔蒙。我们可以自己释放它。我们的大脑并不总能区分出别人给你一个大拥抱与你自己
just wrapping your arms around yourself. I know it sounds really silly, but do it now. Put your arms around yourself and hold them there, squeeze yourself in. It will immediately make you feel better. And it's also a great way to practice self-love as well as healing your inner child. Two for one. What a great deal. Finally, in order to re-parent ourselves, we need to show ourselves that we are a responsible parent for our inner child, that we can be independent and can take care of ourselves. It doesn't mean that we can't accept help from others, but it does mean being able to meet your own needs. Do something nice for yourself. Eat food that is going to make you feel good. Take yourself outdoors, see the sun. Make sure you get good rest, find time to socialize, the same things that you would
双臂环抱自己之间的区别。我知道这听起来很傻，但现在就做。把双臂环抱在自己身上并紧紧抱住，把自己紧紧挤压一下。它会立刻让你感觉更好。这也是练习自爱以及治愈内心的孩童的绝佳方式。一石二鸟。多划算的买卖啊。最后，为了重新养育我们自己，我们需要向自己证明，我们是我们内心孩童的一个负责任的父母，我们能够独立并且能够照顾好自己。这并不意味着我们不能接受他人的帮助，但这确实意味着能够满足你自己的需求。为自己做点好事。吃能让你感觉良好的食物。带自己去户外，看看太阳。确保获得充足的休息，找到时间社交，对待自己要像对待
do for a real life child, you need to do for yourself. And I think it helps our brain really learn that we are not helpless or vulnerable, like the childhood versions of us may still feel. We're not in that wounded place anymore. We're adults now. We're responsible and we can look out for ourselves. We can take care of that little version of us who needed someone else to take care of them. And we can put ourselves on a really fantastic. path. I hope this episode was really useful for those of you out there who are considering doing some inner child work and some inner child healing. I know that it sounds a little bit ridiculous, but as someone who really prioritizes this, as someone who's done the research, looked into
现实生活中的孩子一样。我认为这有助于我们的大脑真正认识到，我们并非无助或脆弱，不像我们童年时的版本可能依然感到的那样。我们不再处于那个受伤的地方了。我们已经是成年人了。我们有责任感，我们可以照顾好自己。我们可以照顾好那个曾经需要别人来照顾的小小的自己。我们可以把自己带上一条真正绝妙的道路。我希望这一集对你们当中那些正考虑进行内在孩童工作和内在孩童治愈的人非常有用。我知道这听起来有点荒谬，但作为一个真正优先考虑这一点的人，作为一个做过研究、了解过
the science, it's incredibly valuable. It's also incredibly valid. And I would really recommend it. Think about how you can integrate those daily practices into your life. Think about how you can take a moment during the week to just be a little bit silly, to just push back a little bit on the responsibilities and seriousness of adulthood. And when you have the time, when you have more time, really dive into why you are the person you are today. What was it about what you experienced as a child that has created you. I think it's really, really valuable. And you'll find that once you really take the time to do that,
科学的人，它是极其宝贵的。它也是极其有效的。我真的强烈推荐它。想想你如何将这些日常练习融入你的生活。想想你如何在这一周里抽出片刻时间来稍微傻气一点，稍微打破一点成年后的责任感和严肃性。当你有了时间，当你有了更多时间时，真正去深入探究为什么你成为了今天的你。是什么让你在童年时经历的事情造就了你。我认为这真的非常非常有价值。你会发现，一旦你真正花时间去这样做，
once you really put in the energy and the vulnerability and the effort, you'll see that your entire outlook and the way you treat yourself and the way you treat others and the way you treat life, it completely changes for the better. So I know that sounds like a bit of a rant, but it is just really something I believe in so deeply and I hope that this encourages you to give it a go as well. Thank you so much for listening.
一旦你真正投入了精力、脆弱感和努力，你会发现你的整个视角、你对待自己的方式、你对待别人的方式以及你对待生活的方式，都会为了变得更好而彻底改变。所以我知道这听起来有点夸夸其谈，但这真的是我深信不疑的事情，我希望这能鼓励你也去尝试一下。非常感谢您的收听。
If you did enjoy this episode and you think someone else would benefit from it, please pass forward, pass on the love. Share it with your mom, share it with your auntie, share it with your best friend, whoever it may be, whoever you think might enjoy this. It really helps the show great. row and I honestly love when people tell me that their parents listen to the show and they're like,
如果你确实喜欢这一集，并且你认为其他人会从中受益，请把它传递下去，传递这份爱。把它分享给你的妈妈，分享给你的阿姨，分享给你的闺蜜，无论它是谁，无论你认为谁会喜欢这个。这真的对节目的成长有很大帮助，老实说，我真的很喜欢当人们告诉我他们的父母也在听这个节目，然后他们说，
oh, my parent loves this. My parent, like, my relationship with my parent has improved so much. That is like the best thing ever. Um, additionally, if you do feel called to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show grow. It helps us reach new people. and just makes my day. Finally, if you want to be more involved in the community, if you want to get updates on what's coming up, on merch, on new episodes,
哦，我的父母很喜欢这个。我的父母，比如，我和我父母的关系改善了太多。那简直是史上最棒的事情。此外，如果你确实觉得有此心愿，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。它真的对节目的成长有很大帮助。它帮助我们接触到新听众，而且让我一整天都有好心情。最后，如果你想更多地参与到这个社群中，如果你想获得关于即将推出的内容的更新、周边商品、新剧集的通知，
if you want to help me choose the episodes that we post here, please follow the podcast at That Psychology podcast on Instagram. We do a lot of stuff over there, so it would be great to have you on board. As always, have a lovely week. Thank you for tuning in. I hope you enjoyed this. this episode and we will be back next week for another episode.
如果你想帮我挑选我们在这里发布的剧集，请在Instagram上关注播客“That Psychology podcast”。我们在那边做了很多内容，所以非常欢迎你的加入。一如既往，祝你度过美好的一周。感谢收听。希望你喜欢这一集，我们下周将带着另一集回归。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个懂行的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人扛着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着
that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
你必须这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次并进行推销，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格，莱斯利，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底被颠覆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience. in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app,
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧度、健康以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一面走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序上收听《2%》，也就是TWA%（注：应为2%），
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to. to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
逃脱。他将得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人制作。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。